Do you know what these eclipse terms mean?
Saros or tzolkinex?
Stars are cool, thats about all I know.
To the untrained ear, they sound like Pokemon!
We hit the streets of D.C.
and the annual anime convention, Otakon to see if people can tell the difference.
Let's do this!
I'm going to say this is the Pokemon, aphelion
or aphe-lion, because it has lion in it.
That seems like it might be a Pokemon name.
Oh, and it was not!
I'm going to say that Heliolisk is the astronomy term.
(Alright... it's actually a Pokemon!)
No!
Oh. You've betrayed me once Pokemon, and probably
will again.
What generation is that from? That's neat looking.
Sys... syzygy.
Yveltal, that's the rare Pokemon from X and Y.
I know what a syzygy is, so a little cheating
there. Yveltal is the Pokemon.
(How do you know what a syzygy is?)
I heard it in songs.
Well, this one's easy!
This should have been question one.
Okay so Gyarados, of course, would be the Pokemon in this case.
I've never heard of Exeligmos, so i'm going
to say that's the astronomy term.
(You'd be right!)
Oh boy.
I can see someone yelling "Zygarde, I choose
you!" so...
Zygarde, that sounds like out of Thor or something,
I was like "no..."
I've heard both of those words before and
I don't know which is which.
Another easy one, the Pokemon is Umbreon!
In fact, I just saw Umbreon a little while ago.
Antumbra is the astronomy term...
Hey, there we go!
OK, Umbreon is the Pokemon. Love my Eevees.
Which is kinda cool because Umbreon and Espeon being like,
requiring day and night cycles when you evolve them.
I think it's right Kristin,
Fine, right... Antumbra.
Yay!
Alright, we got five for five.
I think I did better than I was expecting,
but not very well either way.
This is boosting my Pokemon knowledge, my
science knowledge, and my vocabulary.
This is a good three-fer.
I got five for five, and I think that's because
a lot of the...
He's a total dork!
And also a lot of my friends really like Pokemon
and won't stop talking about it.